this isn't fascinating you guys used
that woop watchin and different kind of
watches to test your heart rate and all
that stuff so Jimmy Johnson war watch
during a race and check that out that's
how much my god yeah that's how much
you're actually stressed out during the
race and says it was an average of 100
and what was that 149 beats per minute
that's Oh God
so that's his heart rate yeah you spent
over 2,500 calories doing a three and a
half hour long race it's a show to show
you how intense those driving sessions
I'm not I'm not disagreeing now if you
wrote a bike for three and a half hours
you can burn way more counter sensing if
you rollerblade for three and a half
hours huh you're gonna burn way more cut
huh if you skateboard for three and a
half hours you're gonna burn a shitload
what about your heart rate if you bike
your heart rates probably not will your
if you bike if your mountain biking was
three half hours you can burn your heart
racing me probably similar maybe not the
highest out how you maintained I see
this point uh I don't know probably I
don't know I'm just saying like that to
me that's like okay oh your heart rates
up like physical right you're using your
whole body in a way you actually are
using your whole body you're you're
reading space you action time yeah and
I'm probably I mean I'm just saying to
me does not matter if you call it a
sport I don't care I literally don't
care people have these debates I know
but if you call sport cool yeah that's
what you don't go well I don't know but
it's like if if you surf for 39 hours
you'll burn more calories if you took a
nice job for 3/9 hours you'd burn more
calories the better with a better
question rather than saying it's a sport
the better thing is this is Jimmy
Johnson athlete that's been the question
meaning like a lot of times we see how
that doesn't work but it does because it
doesn't cuz it's John Daly an athlete I
think he is the big fat John Daly I
think John Daly would probably be good
at throwing a baseball I think you're
wrong I think you're dead wrong why I
mean you ever seen car McGregor throw
baseball or football he's an athlete I
know but so it doesn't ever learn but
someone like John Daly was big like that
I would imagine I wouldn't be spent he
looks like he could be a
sure if he wasn't that happy I think
that's the arrogant to say no I think
it's insane to say you don't know okay I
mean I have an idea it's well because
pitching is a skill but it's a very
specific skill there's many so not all
mmm
there's many people they can pick up a
baseball you'll have to tell me fee and
fill that ball to their athletes I can
give Mark Sanchez up there a basketball
you can't dunk it I'll have to show him
how to dunk it well being announcer then
Jim I'm asking you is Jimmie Johnson I
don't know I have no idea I thought well
you know what I'm saying
the average NASCAR guy I have no idea
but my question for you if you want to
see because he's good athlete that's a
sport is John Daly an athlete well Tiger
Woods it no but that's a good question
because what I'm saying is there are
athlete I would say who that yeah I
would you look there's some else you can
bowl so here's what I mean the average
NBA player there was an FL player is an
athlete in terms of you can they can do
a lot of sports I feel hold on every
person the NFL's an athlete thank you
because they could not every golfers an
athlete not every NASCAR driver is what
I'm asking so that's like I say that's
the question I'm not disagreeing with
you I'm saying that's the question ask
so so in like a if you see if you see
the anybody who plays in the NBA I I
believe is going to have better
coordination speed power strengthen is
an athlete is an all-around athlete it
requires physical dexterity that is off
the charts no one on the planet is gonna
say otherwise that's the term you may be
able to what I'm saying is that I don't
know you can say that about every very
good NASCAR driver I don't know you can
say that about everything every case by
case yeah the fun that was my point like
Tiger Woods ridiculous that I guarantee
and give Tigers a baseball you throw a
baseball not 100 miles an hour he's not
gonna like ridicuious doing it
you give John Daly a baseball or
football might look a little ridiculous
he's never thrown one so I don't know
but yeah I'm sure there's bring John
Daly up naked no now Jimmie Johnson and
then there's Bubba Wallace you know
there's some guys who are pretty
athletic if I can handsome older he
could give a [ __ ] John Daly is John
Daly's
jaw he looks like Joey Diaz in white
face there are some ideas in white
they were saying they were saying about
they were saying about John Daly they
were like he said tigers come hang out
with us I got a practice because Fogg
practice because you could say chime
you're really talented I'm not as
talented as you are he could give two
[ __ ] huh
well they are the same person
it said john daly encouraged that's his
son vodka yeah to get rid of chunky give
to foxy it's great laris i by been guess
it all huh john daly smokes drink ambles
just look guys he's just a [ __ ] maybe
this looks like Joey Diaz
dude he really does he could give a [ __ ]
yeah I don't
yeah I'm again I geez I've never driven
NASCAR I'm sure it's very challenging
I'm sure there's some good athletes but
I don't know great pants he's a colorful
character he's well okay I'm with yummy
Oh My Jesus I mean the biggest kinda
weird oh my lord he's big I can't
believe still alive yeah he's eight foot
though Jesus I don't see yet it's got
one more it's a good one see just to
your argument to be not every UFC
fighters a good athlete I don't know if
that's true
who was you doing it what else who would
you say yeah I see we don't know but I
mean be able to throw a punch I mean to
wrestle not everyone know you think
every I just think it's such an athletic
event I think it's such a the dress will
kick punch is so act it's like so hard
to do well we can learn it you don't
have to have the talent to be able to
wrestle or do jujitsu or box
now there's ones that learn it and have
talent like John Jones Conor McGregor
who are athletes
well I like a guy like DC but no matter
how much I practice don't a baseball or
football if I don't have the talent or
athleticism it doesn't matter I can get
good at Rus and not be that up yeah
that's true
and you can get yeah you can knock
somebody out and not be yeah fighting a
skill it's a lot of skill a lot of ton
of skill yeah yeah it's interesting it's
the weird argument though you know it is
and we all the great athletes are not
going into UFC this is not enough money
they're great get some great athletes
like Conor McGregor or George st. Pierre
you know yeah now what's khabees
vertical with kibby's forty times uh
it's not what you not it's not Oh what's
a five five Brian you'd run a five flat
in the fort I believe that his verticals
by 24 he's just been wrestling his whole
life but that's like lawyer Paul I
learnt that but not like thoughts could
be but football he's probably gonna have
a tough time making the NFL team as well
it's just I'm just saying he's gonna go
to the combines but he's gonna have a
hard time dividing the ball it's just a
weird argue like it's tough like you
look at like marathon runners ultimate
like campaigns
yeah monster dude [ __ ] monster yeah
but I don't know it's 40 is right no
that's that's deep through a combine I
don't think is worth all right it's an
interesting discussion yes yeah
here's my thing I don't care hey Nazca
line hauled sports
I don't do air I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
I'm not the gatekeeper who's the sports
who's not mmm go ahead yeah you guys are
athletes I don't care yeah but that but
that thing to me isn't that impressive
25 more collagen in three half hours I
think what's what's interesting about
that is I didn't think they would even
be burning that much or even be like
their heart wave would beat up that high
heart rate makes sense because you know
you're the drill and stuff like that but
only five let me do four two and out
three and a half hours 25 honey you got
a hike on Runyon up and down 15 hours
you're burning way more than with that
you can visualize you can see why
there's exertion but with you were you
driving a car it just feels like you
wouldn't be exerting that much but you
really you were there it's nuts yep yeah
but even you now you're burning calories
Jen yeah you're right there's no way
it's like that though well I'm just
saying Piper in 400 calories I have no
idea who no I don't think 400 I don't
know yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]